today I will be showing you one of my
games against any time you're a champion
Alexander Shaw below is also going to be
here this May so maybe we'll get to play
again
so we've played many games but this game
played in 2006 and I'm playing with the
white pieces d4 as you probably know by
now that this is the move that I play
with the white pieces I open up the game
with the Queen pawn and Grand Master sha
below is very interesting player he can
play many different openings so when
you're playing him it's very difficult
to predict kind of what opening he's
gonna play so he plays many different
openings so kind of a difficult opponent
to prepare so in this game he decided to
play the Kings Indian defense opening
now I've showed some games when I use
the Petrossian Smith slow Petrossian
system in fact yesterday but today I
will will show you the game where I
played the classical setup so you can
see the both weights you know so before
I played d6 Bishop e2 and right away
here he does something a little bit
surprising the most popular move here is
to play e5 to fight for the center but
instead of doing that you play c6
basically going away from the main
theory and just trying to play some sort
of position where you just you see who
plays better I guess now c6 I castle and
I place this move a six
idea behind this movies to play d5 and
he will try to bother me right playing
this move before to try to move my
knight so you can win the pond now I
play this prophylactic move it's a
useful move to stop the Bishop from
coming to g4 and the night as well most
importantly tonight because I plan to
put my Bishop only three and usually in
this kind of positions you don't want to
put the bishop only three first because
if you do that is going to attack you
then you're going to have to move the
bishop again because you don't want to
lose the dark square bishop so that's
why I play the move h3 first just to
control this position the square now he
plays b5 threatening to play before now
what do you think what is the best move
here for white
well if you play b3 you lose upon he
plays before he Stratos before so if we
go b3 he goes before attacking our nine
if we move the knight he takes the
central pawn so this is what he's trying
to do and I don't want to take because
if I take he takes toward the center
okay so what do you think I can do here
it's possible move Queen c2 but again he
has this before idea I like to make a
move to stop this idea so I don't have
to worry about this all the time
I can play which move a tree yeah it's a
nice move it's accurate move because I
just control the square so he cannot go
here anymore and move my knight away
from c3 okay so this is the best move in
this position now he takes I take back
and he plays the good move here d5
because he needs to fight for the center
here if he doesn't fight for the center
if you allow me to play this move rook
e1 Bishop g5 I have excellent Center and
all my pieces very nicely developed so
he has to do something Knight takes e4
is a possibility yes but I take d5 I'll
go be shipped here I mean if you look at
the position still you know it's got
lots of pieces you know that he still
needs to develop and he spars a bit weak
in particular the c6 pawn okay
so now
he didn't let you play d5 now what
should I do here
how should I try to react in this
position after this defy break because
he wants to break my Center and activate
his pieces to equalize the scheme well
there are some other options too but I
mean such as taking the pawn but for
example if I take he takes back this is
very bad for me because basically I
exchange it my exchange my good pawn for
the pawn on c6 this will be a positional
mistake he will at least equalize the
game so I simply go here and now after I
go Bishop d3 he played Knight bd7
I played Bishop III pushing the pawn is
a possibility yes yes
b5 well 98 it's not as clear now it's
absolutely playable move
it's a playable move but then I was you
know I have to worry about the c5 moment
some point like this should be 75
okay I mean you can play five it's a
playable move but I thought I should
develop my pieces it's also important to
do that so I play Bishop III and also I
play the h3 move yeah so I can put my
bishop here sided that Bishop e3 he
takes I take it was 95 he also take my
bishop now and remember you don't want
to allow him to take this bishop in the
Kings Indian opening because it's an
open position he will have the pair of
the bishops so he had to make sure you
don't give him the dark square Bishop
yeah it's a it's a tat but what if he
just starts breaking the center and he's
got the pair of the bishops here if you
have the bishops you open up the
position that's what he's trying to do
is trying to open the position see I
might I don't think I have any deities
here
okay so not Queenie to
it's an idea Bishop g5 move the bishop
to more active square okay so I will
here first putting some pressure now
after Bishop g5 he plays h6 attacking my
bishop and now where should I retreat
this bishop see this would be a natural
but then I lose control of this square
and then he's jumping and attacking my
pieces so now I go Bishop d2 but this is
very important because h6 is now going
to be weak in many positions so this is
going to be a loose pawn and also
sometimes there could be some tactics
because g6 is not as strong anymore so
it's very useful for me to induce this
move h6 I could have gone here right
away Bishop d2 but then he's very very
solid so I go here first he weakens the
position and then I go here why it is a
slightly better position here but again
when you have a slightly better position
you have to try to play really precisely
to develop this slightly better position
to the next one big advantage now Bishop
d2 he goes Queen b6 and for a moment
looks like it's a little problem
attacking two pawns here
and he always wants to play like Bishop
d7 and c5 try to get rid of his backward
pawn on c6 the week one so which one is
the best here for me
Queen c1 is a possibility yes I probably
just plays King h7 what else remember I
mentioned you don't want to lose that
Bishop Knight takes c3 your dark square
Bishop is very valuable you have to have
one rupee one it's possible but I don't
want to be like you know keeping my
valuable group just to defend one pawn
correct the point is you play b4u fixes
both weaknesses what are the weaknesses
when opponent has weak pawns you fix
this pawn so you cannot advance them
anymore so that's why you play before
here now he cannot play a five because I
take he cannot place if I because I take
C now he's got two weaknesses
I mentioned earlier regarding this pawn
on d4 but he cannot take it yet because
if he takes i take he takes then he
loses the pawn on h6 again we come down
to that h6 move that in a lot of lines
it's hanging now it's a bad position for
him because I have two bishops position
of this King is also weak so before is a
very important move I was very happy
after this move because I felt like I
have a nice advantage here now he plays
Luke d8 now what do you do next you need
to play very logical nothing really
wrong with that ball but you need to
finish your development before you start
thinking of attacking and I think there
are a couple of moves you want to make
here first before you think of an attack
absolutely see in some lines this rook
is going to be hanging here so I want to
move the rook away so it's not going to
be hanging and now immediately applying
pressure to the weak pawn if there is a
weak pawn you put pressure on it you
make these pieces just to defend
passively now he goes Knight f8 can you
find another move combining development
and putting pressure it's a possible
move a little bit better than that
a little bit better than that more
active
now look see 5 equals 96 cent correct
Queen a 4 queen is more active on a for
putting pressure on this weakness now in
this position my opponent realize I mean
if he just starts to defend like puts
the bishop here it's just going to be
very very passive and I can go 95 and
that thing to take c6 is very weak so he
decided to sacrifice this pawn and
activate his pieces I think this is the
right idea because at least now he gains
activity so it was 96 putting pressure
on the pawn and also he has some
possibilities like Knight f4 now what do
you do
rook takes pawn and you go scream b8 I
had to spend some time here because it
looks great for me but he does have some
threats here he does have this threat
first of all he does have some Knight
jumps so I need to find one move that
will stop these ideas and make them not
as strong here one precise move here
will stop this ideas
don't rush it's not easy move I must
have spent at least 15 minutes here
because I know I'm better but it's not
so clear he's got too many threats as
you see Knights are jumping this pawn is
hanging too
it's why to play yes
if it says Smoove he would just go
Bishop d7 and I'm in trouble
right I was exchanged yeah but then I
dropped the d4 pawn and he could also go
Knight f4 and just start perhaps
attacking me push the beep on ah well if
we push the b-pawn he goes here still
attacks my rook and if I move back he
could capture it and then my queen is
hanging to so I would wouldn't be that
good for me
correct the end very good Queen a5 it's
a very nice book because now first of
all you move the Queen away so Bishop d7
it's not effective anymore
now you're putting pressure on the rook
and you're putting pressure on the night
and still putting pressure on the a6
pawn now he can't just move his knight
from here because he loses the rook ok
Queen a5 and he cannot also take this
pawn same reason he drops his rook
if you place Bishop d7 I was thinking of
this nice idea sacrifice the exchange
destroy the pass structure and go
Knights e5 and I have so many threats
now pawn is hanging the other pawn
hanging I can just go rook e1 even
though I'm down exchange but this is
practically winning position for me in
some positions you have to know when to
sacrifice in exchange for something like
this you definitely go for it
sacrifice pawns are weak night is very
powerful on c5 and then you go rook e1
because you need to bring your last
piece into the game that rook on f1 yeah
so bring that make sure you always do
that even if you have like a very strong
attack try to include all your pieces in
so of course he's not going to allow me
to take only six so he played the best
move he has Knight d2 F for activating
his knight and now he wants to go Bishop
f4 so at this point temples are very
valuable here he is attacking my bishop
I don't have time to just move it
because if I move the bishop then I get
under more attack on this diagonal so
that's why I will have to take this
Knight now he cannot take back with his
Knight because he loses the rope so he
has to take with a queen but at least at
this point he's not attacking anything
and now good move here for white
correct very nice move centralizing the
position of the night and now putting
more pressure on day six pawn my goal is
to win this pawn because if I win this
pawn we go to any end game I will be
winning because I have two connected
past problems any end game we go with
two connected equal material I will just
win now not so clear what he can do but
he found a move Bishop takes d4 the idea
is if I take his knight he takes with a
bishop and at the same time he is
connecting his rooks and he's protecting
it
now what do you do now
yes
aha a very good idea take the bishop
right bishop is in the center and
opponent his two bishops let's take the
bishop eliminate that now again he
cannot take with a knight as in many of
the variations because the rook is
hanging so he took with the rock here
and now he got his palm back
with what can I do here huh
correct with which case don't rush don't
drop your Bishop on d3 Fisher Bishop
takes if I saved of course now I have my
two connected passed pawns if I can
neutralize his activity here we go to an
endgame I should be winning this not
going to be that easy because it does
have some activity now he took on c5 now
my goal is here just to liquidate more
pieces I can exchange it will be better
for me very good Queen takes e5 but you
have to see this tactical variation if
it takes for the bishop the rook takes
Bishop rook takes check and take so we
reach this position okay with two pounds
yes
Farooq takes it it's possible but the
problem is we are not liquidating as
much here and he can try to organize an
attack here because he's got that night
he's got a night rookin queen and
they're very active and check from where
here now he's got some pressure you know
it's so that's I Knight is very
dangerous
usually when opponent is attacking you
with the rook queen and night it's very
dangerous so try to make sure the knight
is not there so that's why I took with
the Queen okay
Queen takes e5 now he doesn't want to go
too
you know he wants to keep some pieces on
the board so he goes here Bishop d7 now
what do you do your rook is under attack
we're up to see seven correct again you
have to calculate the tactics top
because looks like you're losing your
bishop but you're not what do you do
take the bishop off takes check and
which rookie gonna take you can take
this one because you lose your pawn so
if you take here he takes this pawn you
take this one and he goes here he wins
this opponent and I have to agree to a
draw so okay so that's why I take this
one and we get the same position where I
have two connected passed pawns my king
is safe and I start slowly advancing
these pawns
it's technical but I think why should be
winning now after rook c7 he plays q g7
so now he's threatening to take already
because no more background check now
what do you do
which will of course it's a passport
right
you advance the past pawn and protect
your bishop more you advance the past
pawn stronger it's going to get so
always use your passports b5 now he
plays a five
and now very important move you need to
find here so I can't really push here
because I will lose the bishop rook e8
yes and he plays rook e8 the problem is
I have to go back to the same square so
always when we make an active move try
to see what he can do also don't just
assume you make an active move he is
going to defend now what would be the
best move in this position it's possible
move but
I'm not too worried about him advancing
the e pawn because his rook is hanging
he can't really do that there is
something that I want to do and I I just
mentioned that idea actually earlier I
mentioned that idea even earlier look a
seven you could but let's compare our
rooks let's look at your rock on a c7
and the rook on a eight you don't want
to exchange even if you're winning you
don't want to exchange you're very
active piece against them correct rook
e1 is the move
I mentioned remember bring your last
piece into the game and this is what I
did in the game and I bring back in the
game with the tempo attacking something
okay so always make sure you bring all
your pieces into the game now he has to
go here to be ten he cannot afford to
lose another pawn here but now when he
moved his rook what can I do absolutely
continue advancing the pawn getting
stronger now this pawn every time you
push it's going to get stronger now in
this position he realized if you just
place some normal most he's just going
to lose after b7 I will just simply
promote a pawn into a queen so he
decided to take a chance it sacrifice
practically a good decision but this is
more of a desperate attempt here if I go
wrong maybe he can get a perpetual but
strong place they're going to do this
take in there you know if they see
they're just losing by normal moves they
can try to sacrifice something to
complicate it
what are you gonna do now yes well I
took the peace sacrifice of course but
he check I'm not sure if you're going to
be able to go King f1 because well now
check what are you going to do now I'll
kink to h1 then he goes Queen - your
puns are little bit loose you know
you're going to lose f2 maybe you're
lose h3 you could made it see I don't
mind losing a pawn here as long as I can
get my Bishop into the game of course
King f1 now Queen f5 it seems like it's
got a little bit of threads here the h3
is hanging of course it's not very
serious threats here but one precise
movement after that it's clear that you
cannot do anything
Eero could go up to III but it's I
wouldn't say it so clearly I wrote the
one check or quintics Rock yeah but I
mean is this this is that clear
check takes might be still winning but
rookie 7x take on table still winning
but I don't need to sacrifice my queen
here I have something better well
Bishop see it actually I might lose you
know because it takes if I take I get
mated check mate see there are still
there is still some you know details
here you know you have to pay attention
on okay
well I bring your queen Quincy tree is a
possibility but which fish you think
would be nice to have in the game
defending our king here that is not
really doing much right now
of course of course now we need to bring
our Bishop to g2 once you bring the
bishop on g2 he cannot even create a
single thread Sarah Bishop d7 and he
cannot just push this part to block me
because I take the Rock Shack
so now Queen takes h3 check Bishop g2
you should back in again to defend I
goes check King g1 and I go to g4
threatening to play Queen f3
Queen c6
Queeny trees probably winning move also
proceeded by every
well you want to try to win this epon
with a check and also exchange some more
pieces okay that's what you want to do
here the easiest way to win here that's
what I play now I'm trying to take check
and it will be a maid so he has to take
now in this position he didn't play
queen f2 but let's take a look what's
gonna happen if he does that how are you
going to win this now
H to have to play accurately because if
you go to g3 he can still take it and
it's still pinned okay so you just go
here and that's it he cannot do anything
so now he played rook g5 because he you
want to lose this pawn and after my next
move you resigned here of course push
the pot because now if you go screen f3
push push mate I don't want to get mated
let's take the rock yeah it's a little
nicer
it takes take the claim okay so after I
push the pawn on b7 he resigned so
basically as you see in the opening I
got a slightly better position and then
I just try to improve the pieces move by
move and then increase Maya - advantage
from slightly better to a big advantage
and winning position okay now we're
going to do of some endgame positions
okay some very important endgame
positions it's white to play and you
need to find a way how to make a draw
here because it looks like your Luke is
hanging and your bishop is hanging well
I'll think about it for a little bit
think about it for a few moves it's
white to play
I think well don't rush here don't rush
now we'll check your answer make sure
it's 100% correct before because you may
think you have it but this is a very
many books disposition but this is there
is a usable book they have this but some
other books also say the problem is we
have two pieces hanging so if we lose
one of this pieces and we don't have
anything concrete we will lose this game
and we cannot just go back because check
and wins the rock
well unless you have something
extraordinary after you lose a piece
there are some suggestions let's see
Bishop AHA a hat see like that you have
to calculate here you may think you can
keep checking but you may end up not
being able to do that okay go ahead keep
checking see I will play accurately here
now you can check me from here I tick
with the Queen and no more still made
check I go here I go here and then where
the last time maybe we don't we don't
really have that checks all the time
because he's going to take with the
Queen other direction from or checking
from here that's very similar I go here
okay
I think most most most of you are
thinking when I set up you like oh I
have it
II thought okay it will just be Bishop
c2 but not so simple not so simple
yeah but then my king will go on the
back squares and you don't have time to
solidify your pieces Jack loses to King
g7 now you can't solidify them with
checks you lose your rock and let's say
you go here to defend I go check and you
run out of good ideas because if you go
up check you lose your rock if you go
side check you lose your rock so it's
Bishop - you mean d2 is here but you
can't you mean sick - or yeah
Bishop a4 we have a suggestion
interesting and what if I just play King
here can you consolidate your position
that's a point skewer okay still mate
that's the idea you have to use to draw
but Bishop a4 I don't think it works
because I go here and then we have some
problem with the consolidation here
yeah but he goes back to a1 same
position now I just go here and now I
want to take the problem is the pieces
are not coordinated and then with some
couple of good checks I will win the
rook or the bishop so that's the problem
with this move
aha very nice but did you calculate all
the lines for the interest guess the
move because there were lots of
suggestions so we almost run out of all
the moves here I mean the moves you know
okay let's see why this book possibly
can work so if it takes the rook your
you know what you do Bishop c2 takes
still mate but maybe I can take this
piece now it's very important to give a
check from a correct square here so
let's say if you check from ec7 itza you
lose I go here check check uh-huh it's
actually sorry sorry here and you run
out of checks because checks now I take
with the Queen and I you know no more
still mate so what are you going to do
now
check now this is after you have to
calculate because it's a lot of moves
here let's see king g6 go ahead rook h6
King f5
rogue eight-six I go here check
shop check
so here sorry
you see where I'm trying to be I'm
trying to go to 83
aha finally see this the position I want
you to reach now squares are taken
so I'm just trying to go to a four and
simply come to a three looks like I
might be able to win this one lets you
find something really strong for white
now if I go here it's just just still
checking so I have to go here now only
move only move rook a five because if
you will give another check after King
III you lose because if you sacrifice
this way I take with the Queen
no more still mate and mate only one and
if you play now rook h3 I still take and
again not still mate so but idea is
check you want to give up the rock
he takes still mate and if it goes King
before final move Rock be fine basically
you want to lose your rock but make sure
you keep the Queen on b3 okay that's the
idea you want to make sure you keep the
Queen on b3 let's go back and do this
one again it's a it's a difficult one
so we're trying to coordinate our pieces
and the only way we can do it is to go
Bishop b3 here because he cannot take
right away the rock because of the
bishop c2 threat so he takes and now we
check from h4 97 check
now we reach this position now you find
a move a five check
stimate if you go skiing before check X
yeah okay it's about 12 moves now let's
see if I play King h6 now what you're
going to do what you're going to do here
to consolidate your position
you have to give a check from here only
move
with which piece though you can also
protect this way but loud losses correct
with the king you protect your bishop
protects you look your king protects
your bishop he cannot do anything - now
move your king away from the bishop ok
this is a very important idea the reason
you have to find bit should be true
because in the position like this when
it's an open board its queen is very
strong you may think you put your oak
away but you know with couple of precise
checks is going to fork your King to the
rock so you have to really calculate it
now Bishop b3 what if you go scheme g7
what do you do yes rookie 7 check say I
play King - f8
check from f7 aha
you put your roof where the bishop is
guarded and then you simply come up with
the king it's very important to get this
disposition where the bishop is
protecting the rook okay when you reach
this position the end game where you
have a queen versus rook you actually
have to really know how to win this
position because if you think oh I will
just win because I have a queen versus
rook it's not it's not going to happen
so you can reach this position and this
happened to I remember
a motorcy [ __ ] very strong Russian
Grand Master had once the position he
couldn't win he came very close but he
didn't know this idea he was right here
but he was he was few moves away from
winning but then he just didn't know how
to do it well can't really lose with the
Queen versus the rookie I mean he draw
the game but do you know how to win this
position no 404 white for though I
believe yeah we can be quick we'd be
five and make a dry ashes now there were
there was like very strong grandmasters
they couldn't win this position king and
queen versus rook and King it's it's not
as simple you know how to win this okay
good good then
oh you don't have to calculate that much
it's just to moose okay correct
Queen a5 or you can get the same
position by checking and here okay it
doesn't matter it's it's same idea so
you have to get a position like this
where it's his turn it he cannot move
the king we put him into a position
where he can I move the king then he's
going to have to move the rock he has to
move the rock let's try to see the
squares he can go to well this you
cannot go here because he just loses the
rock that's the point so let's look at
this course you can go to one two three
here four squares here now we'll look at
each square Y this is losing so let's
start up with this side so if you go see
a check we take correct so now it goes
here now how are you going to win the
rock
precisely if it goes here it's mate so
he has to go here
we
oh you could probably also win with yak
winner for check that's good now he
cannot go here mate he has to go to the
a file now and then we never correct
queena for wins now if you place now
here loses immediately check so now the
last move is here now you have to see
from which squares you can fork the rook
and a king so you can fork in from here
or from here right if the king is on a
seven and you start calculating how can
I get that position
just three moves and you win the rock
three moves can you find it
I could do that but how about we check
from here he cannot go here it's made so
you can only go to a 1 or B 8 so here
let's say he goes here now check he
cannot go back because nice King gets in
the corner you go all the way back here
and mate you have to always look at all
64 squares so you can see this long
range moves now he goes here now I see
now check and we win the rock okay check
it take all right
now let's take a look what's going to
happen if it goes here so let's start
that with rook f7
check
okay
check he cannot go here mate and if it
goes to the background fork win the rook
so if it goes here loses immediately to
check right and now the last move rook
h7 now again you can fork in from here
or here sorry here so now you need to
find a way how you can get your Queen to
this course
Queen b6 King a8
so when it we needed to go away we need
to go down here to for Kim right so we
can start with like for example check so
it goes back check it goes back make and
if it goes here check check
take the rock so and if he goes here you
can check you cannot go to see it
because it's made so if he goes here
check
check-check and you reach this position
because now if it goes here you check in
you take the rock what if it goes here
what do you do
ga check and win the rock
so basically when you're trying to win
this position you have to try to get to
this position and then go either Queen
Queen a5 right away and he's in a souk
Subang because here he gets mated or you
can also get this position check here
and now again he cannot do anything so
this is the crucial position to reach if
you're trying to convert the position
with a king and queen versus king and
rook if the rook moves further away with
precise checks you're going to be able
to win the rook
you
you